can democracy still deliver president
biden is determined to show the world
that it can and will the white house
today opened a virtual gathering with
representatives from over a hundred
countries the two-day summit for
democracy is part of an effort to
counter authoritarian regimes but the
guest list is raising lots of questions
and the summit also comes at a fragile
time for america's own democracy as we
approach the one-year anniversary of the
siege of the u.s capitol so let's
discuss all of this with michael brown
with he is president of freedom house
it's a non-profit that conducts research
and advocacy on political freedom and
human rights michael welcome to quick
take before we get to who's attending
who's not and the timing
what does biden want to accomplish with
this summit what would success look like
for him
well i think the president has properly
identified
the rise of authoritarianism and the
kind of corresponding decline of
democracy which we at freedom house have
chronicled over the past 15 years
is a very serious problem for the world
uh this is uh
they're not presidents who have really
tried to put the focus on this issue the
way he has he said during the campaign
that he hoped that he would hold a
summit and he's and he's doing it so i
think what he hopes to gain from this is
to try to
build solidarity and greater attention
from the world's democracies to do
better to function more effectively and
to be better prepared to counter the
authoritarian threat
michael what was your reaction to the
guest list was there anyone included who
you found to be a little bit surprising
and was there anyone excluded that you
thought was interesting
well i certainly think the guest list
was kind of a
function if you will of a little bit of
geopolitics i think most of the
countries uh that are at the summit you
know we have no problems with there are
they are they're democracies you know
some are stronger democracies than
others you know there are a few
countries that have been invited that uh
are you know say a little bit weird uh
you know one that comes to mind would be
pakistan uh which has not been uh
performing strongly as far as democracy
is concerned in our ratings but once you
invite india to the summit then you then
the united states couldn't get away with
not inviting uh pakistan so i think
certainly there are geopolitics involved
i think the important thing
to really focus on though is what we're
trying to get out of the summit and the
point is that every country that has
come to the summit has has to make some
kind of commitment
of how they are going to prove how
they're going to improve their
own democracy how they're going to
support
uh the growth of democracy whether it's
supporting independent journalism
fighting corruption there are a lot of
things that people can do and so i think
the test for whether this summit is a
success will come over the next couple
of years when we see whether the
countries actually deliver on what they
promised to do today and then and in the
next few months gotcha no instant
results in other words so one
country or one government that's been
invited is taiwan which officially is
not even a country right um this has
caused a lot of anger on beijing's part
because beijing still considers taiwan
to be part of china what is the u.s
hoping to accomplish here what message
is it trying to send and what can taiwan
really
offer and contribute to this summit
well one thing that's really amazing
about taiwan is that in a world in which
we have
a lot of backsliding democracies a lot
of
violations of human rights taiwan is
actually a a kind of a success story
30 to 40 years ago it was essentially a
military dictatorship
today
for a lot of different reasons a lot of
hard work on the part of the taiwanese
people it is one of the most thriving
democracies in the world and i would say
it also has kind of given a lie to the
idea that the chinese people are not
interested in democracy because uh it's
the chinese people who
who inhabit taiwan
so i think china the mainland china is a
bit threatened by this maybe a lot
threatened by this uh and they're not
happy
that taiwan is there but i think it was
a good call by the administration
because we really believe at freedom
house that that taiwan uh is really a
strong defender of human rights
democracy freedom and it's good to see
them there
michael i want to get your take on the
administration's kind of
defense of of democracy within the u.s
right i mean we're approaching the
one-year anniversary of the capital
insurrection
former president trump calling the
election results into question even
though we know that's not uh that's not
true but you know how does biden defend
the state of democracy in the u.s during
this summit
well first of all we have to be honest
that u.s democracy has not been
functioning as well as we would hope it
would be functioning uh in the in recent
years
at freedom house
we put out an annual survey of kind of
the health of democracy every year and
just as there's been an erosion of
democracy around the world we see over
the last 10 years there's been an
erosion of democracy in the united
states now we have to have some context
for that
the fact is the united states is still
a free country
a lot of great elements of its democracy
uh i'm a former reporter like you uh
it's a it's a great country for
safeguarding
journalists for having strong legal
protections for journalism which is a
cornerstone of democracy uh but but
we've had trouble and and i do think
that the bible administration has not
shied away from that it strikes me that
in the comments that i've seen from the
president the secretary of state and
others there has been a recognition
that uh the united states also has to
try to improve its own democracy
not easy there's such polarization it's
very difficult to get things through the
u.s congress but i do think that the
great thing about america is that uh we
there's a capacity for renewal and so i
think uh it's appropriate for us to have
the summit and it's appropriate for the
president and others to acknowledge some
of the shortcomings in u.s democracy the
shortcomings and perhaps the
contradictions as well because another
test of u.s democracy is how a lot of
republican-led states are
passing voting restrictions one year
before the midterms even as certain
places like new york city are looking to
let non-citizens vote in local elections
as well the definition of democracy and
who gets to participate in it changes
according to where you are and each side
can claim that they're doing the right
thing
correct we're we're a federal system
it's up to the states uh how they're
going to run elections uh there are 50
they're 50 different rules for how
that's going to happen and there's no
question
that the uh something that is kind of
sacrosanct to democracy which is the
right to vote has become deeply
politicized i mean we think that uh it
should be
uh it's an honor to be able to vote and
we think it you know there should be as
few restrictions as possible uh we
recognize that sometimes states have to
take steps to make sure that that that
that
that votes that there's integrity to the
voting but
as far as i can see there's not been
really significant
fraud in u.s elections over the last
number of years in fact most independent
studies say that u.s elections certainly
the one in 2020 was well run so it's
disappointing to see efforts to uh to
restrict voting well you know michael
it's interesting we haven't even had
time to touch on russia in this
discussion which is obviously a huge uh
issue right now as well but i'm curious
in your view to what extent do summits
like this have an impact on on global
freedom uh and really move the needle
here
i think they can have a potential impact
i think we have to be a little bit uh
uh honest that uh there's a lot of
factors that go into the health of
democracy and just having a two-day
summit it's nice
i do think it's very significant that
the united states president is devoting
two whole days of his schedule to try to
you know
draw attention to the challenges facing
democracy i think this is one of the
biggest issues in the world today up
there with global warming and uh and i
think it's very significant that the
united states is having this summit is
trying to you know focus attention on
this very serious problem
now we have to deliver on that or the
u.s government and the other democracies
that have come to the summit have to
deliver and try to and try to be more
effective in in protecting democracy if
we're if we're on this show a year or
two from now and there's been not much
progress i worry that it will deepen
cynicism so you know the president has
properly called the summit but he also
we also now need to deliver all right
well michael we'll have to follow up
with you a year or two from today
michael really appreciate your time with
us that was michael abramowicz president
of freedom house